[Musique]
je m'appelle jeanne clérec je suis
architecte en bâtiment voici mon
collègue un suppôt une tisane et puis
1.6 mais la super voisine marcel et
enfin ma raison de vivre à mes deux
enfants et bien sûr le papa qui va avec
j'ai rencontré quelqu'un enfin presque
je vais présenter quoi et on va prendre
un avocat
tant que je pensais qu une garde
alternée pardon j'avais donc avez raison
ça va plus il n'en fut rien
[Musique]
non notre part mais c'est moi
voilà alors en fait cet appareil à matha
et en plus tu vas t'enfoncer vous
mentionnez pas du tout mais paniquons
pas tout va bien très bien mais c'est
pas ce qui m'arrive mais je veux que ça
s'en aille et après lève la mère de
famille avec une [ __ ] c'est quand même
très gênant les vitaux de la vérité
quelle mug beau monde a pas rêvé de
savoir ce que c'était devrait avoir une
fois pas du tout si ça se trouve tu va
voler
on se lève on se serre la main et on
travaille ensemble spécial en ce moment
on sait pas trop ce qu'est là mais il
n'y a pas de souci il est à venir c'est
quoi votre truc avec les filles je veux
dire comment vous y prenez quoi
s'habiller selon papa tu joues là je
crois que tu étais pas un homme
j'en avais allait super les femmes tu
vois les assume pas ce qu'elles n'ont
pas peur allez tout ira bien
vous êtes sûr parce que vous vous avez
l'air très inquiet comment du temps à du
tout du tout du tout tarif jallet
[Musique]
hu